morning again, dear
brother.This is the
third time I have slept with you.It
doesn't hurt at all.My heart is warmer than the pain.What are you
doing in your room?  I'm
sleeping soundly.
Good morning, Nafumi. See you
again? Tora-san. Good morning. You
must not enter this room. How many times do I have to warn you to make you understand?
I am Naofumi-sama
's shield. I will always be with you no matter what.
If I were to be your shield, I should protect your sleep.You
shouldn't disturb me.It's up to Naofumi-sama to decide whether or not to disturb you.Oh, I
told you so much not to come here, so
why did you stay silent?
Anyway, I'm going to get out of here.I'm going with
Mr. Fu.